so when in the 20 years we we I mean it
we've talked about it on thank you for
the prayers yeah you're welcome
the Comedy Store podcast we talked about
it but I don't think a lot of my
listeners have heard the story so I
think we should just kind of give him a
little history real quick all right
let's start over when I first came to LA
in 1997 Ellen yeah that's when I first
moved I think I met you before that I
was a San Diego yeah and I was friends
with we don't have to get into him
because and I've owned I've only said
great things about him on the podcast
but I was friends with Freddy Soto and
he was your best friend
yeah there was they were like so close
and Freddy and I had a thing and when it
came up to LA remember you first coming
and we went to was a Ben Franklin or
Melser right right
and we were trying to help you like
you're gonna sign with worthy like no no
and then you signed we told you not to
do you're like I'm gonna do that yeah
because I thought worthy was I really
thought worthy was real and he was the
only one that was any kind of Richard I
mean interest I don't say Richard why
did you say Richard Richard I mean right
he was interested and he loved comics so
he was yeah he was a hustler definitely
so I signed with him and then it slowly
turned bad for me with Freddie where he
just wouldn't talk to me and then you
know I say why are you're not gonna say
well I mean I the reason why I know the
reason why it's not the reason why you
think it is okay yeah so there was a
fight that I had with Freddie yeah in La
Jolla you saw about the Fred burns right
right and that I believe right was was
the separation between him and I if we
went to blows almost yeah yeah yeah and
so when I came to LA
I don't wanna get into it because the
thing is that I only have positive
things to say about Freddie I love him
so much and you know he passed
unfortunately and but when I came to LA
Eleanor and Freddie's girlfriend
princess Cory mm-hmm that's a real name
selfie no no I Philippine Y the only
Filipinos name their children out there
like Princess Diana or Elton John
[Laughter]
princess
Oh tell Eleanor some of the weird names
that Filipinos out Manny Pacquiao's
daughter Manny Pacquiao you could've
just stopped his daughter's name Queen
Elizabeth it's weird right
what are some other weird like this
fixture like are you yeah but that's not
what your face said you're like she's
half no I'm Filipino that's what I
identify with I understand that but I
think genetically you're half
what's the other well it's up to its
it's really Bobby's position yeah little
friend no she's half Egyptian okay not
that I'm racist but I can oh that's her
name was just Corey and that people just
called her Princess Corey no she called
herself princess Corey and then people
just went okay that's we're gonna call
she's wearing a ball gown why were we
questioning she had a tiara and a ball
gown like on Monday morning do you think
people that change their names they just
one day just wake up and they just say
no you're calling me this from now on
YAG sting i'm sting now and then you're
like oh hey sting or the edge right like
what's his real name
you should know why Kai whoa
that's his MO that we found a real we
found a real one we found a real I know
it scares me on a daily basis but yeah
it's I know it's very scary
he sounds like somebody get doing an
impression of a why why you get so pink